[Music]
i've been thinking
and
i do want to have kids
with you
[Music]
you're not scared anymore oh no i am so
scared maybe even more so than before
but i was scared in there with pam too
and
you know i didn't panic or mess anything
up there if anything i was sharper and
it was a freaking debate genius debate
genius oh that's very hot oh that's an
added bonus okay keep that energy up but
the point that i was actually trying to
make is
maybe it's a good thing that i'm scared
of fatherhood you know maybe it'll turn
me into a friggin dad genius we did it
ames
we made the world's hottest baby
say cute jake no this kid is liquid fire
crazy to think in just 17 short years
he's gonna be six foot seven in the
number one draft pick for the knicks hmm
and then he's gonna pass up that
opportunity to pursue his true passion
library sciences well the important
thing is we'll support him no matter
what even if he's a huge huge nerd oh
especially then
are we gonna be okay at this
i mean this entire day felt like a
warning from the universe i almost
missed the birth we had our baby at the
precinct a firefighter touched our child
we washed him off yeah but i'll always
know babe we talked about this
everyone balances working kids yeah but
everyone's not a cop true but
when our son wants to hear about the day
he was born we get to tell him that his
dad helped a bunch of people and foiled
a bank robbery
i guess that is kind of cool
and his mom managed a city-wide
emergency while actually giving birth
i'm proud for her son to have you as a
dad
me too
for you to be the mom i was just
agreeing with the nice thing you said
about me hey crazy what a good mood mac
is in you mean given the fact that he
was locked into prison by charles how
long did he sleep you mean before he was
rescued from the prison he was locked in
by charles
i guess
three hours whoa what did charles do you
mean besides lock you in a prison got it
i'll stop asking well whatever he did
i'm loving his mood whatever i'm taking
off the case because you both asked for
reduced hours to focus on child care and
santiago has a big presentation this
week if our pilot program to reimagine
how uniformed officers are deployed gets
funded it will represent a significant
reform for the nypd sir we can take care
of mac and still do both of our jobs
trust me we've got this whole parenting
thing figured out it's true we're great
and mac is great i mean the only teeny
tiny issue is that he isn't pulling
himself up yet but the window for that
is 9 to 12 months so the fact that he's
10 months old and isn't doing it yet
doesn't mean that we're bad parents and
i was reading that simone biles went
straight from crawling to walking so
yeah i guess i should be concerned that
my son is on the same track as a
multiple gold medal winner i mean get
real sir
[Laughter]
so yeah mac's having um a little trouble
pulling up but did that convince you to
give us more responsibility it's him
it's really francia don't ask how i know
cause it has nothing to do with lamps
jake what are you doing here what are
you doing here you're supposed to be
getting back from daycare
it's finally down did you miss anything
important with your case
yes because jokers are wild charles went
to the joker stairs and there was
graffiti of the victim's name written on
a bus stop so charles got on the bus
took it to the end of the line where
there was a pay phone ringing he picked
it up and there was a voice on the other
end that told him a riddle
i don't know he had to go before he
could tell me because he noticed that
his kitchen window was mysteriously
unlocked stupid franzia's probably in
his house right now trying to murder him
and his family at least he's not here
trying to murder me and mac i appreciate
you trying to make me feel better aims
but we both know you're grasping at
straws
thank god charles is fine nobody in the
house
i would have been so jealous i'm sorry
babe i'd say i'd take over max stuff for
the week but i have to rewrite my whole
presentation to be snappier and also
according to terry i need to learn how
to walk with my shoulders and not my
feet it's okay what you're doing is
super important i'll just scale back and
let charles run point on the franzia
case no
none of us are scaling back we can be
good parents without sacrificing our
careers we just have to work as a team
you know what yes you're right we got
this all we need is each other there's
been a lice outbreak at daycare and
they're closing for the next two days
what no we need so much more than each
other
ugh damn it none of our regular
babysitters are available and my parents
are out of town and my brother david
can't help because he's in digging wells
for somebody or something i don't know i
hung up on him my dad's out too that's
all he said didn't give a reason
wait i've got it let's just let mac
watch tv all day jake we've talked about
this no screen time for mac until he
turns two ah his first screen time this
is amazing which transformers movies you
to watch first there's an argument to be
made for bumblebee as it is a prequel
jake all right fine just let it auto
play whatever garbage it wants and let's
go okay
here you go mac hello here you go
yeah we deserve that stress is making my
head itch yeah it's weird i've actually
been itching myself no nice scratching
it makes it worse is that true i don't
know i don't have time to know it's true
okay okay let's just stay calm when i
had lice in the fifth grade my mom put a
bunch of maple syrup in my hair and it
smothered them to death it was actually
kind of cool you can hear their tiny
screams
[Music]
oh we already have three applicants
great hire them i think we should
interview them first but what if they're
bad you know let's not waste any more
time looking for babysitters we'll just
take mac in to work with us
see ames we got this yeah this is not
gonna be hard you wanna know why cause
we're great parents in fact we forgot
mac we left our child inside
charles fill me in
and he breaks in the case
if you sing everything as a lullaby mac
won't wake up i understand
the handyman has an alibi
but i found something else so great
thank you the lab techs analyzed
francia's phone call there were two
other voices in the background jake has
waited years for this no he can make the
arrest without me without you there is
no presentation i'll take mac
are you sure
yes absolutely
all right now go everyone get out of
here come on
love you
so we have to switch over to night
vision charles it's all so awesome but i
actually have to stop you because i
gotta go i have to feed this baby some
mushed up avocado
oh my god what happened is mac okay
he just pulled himself up
i'm gonna get ready for bed okay
you're gonna wake up mac and see if
he'll pull up aren't you obviously he is
not sleeping until he does it again all
right well don't go without me cause i
want to see you i'm sober terry i've
been suspended for 87 days matt gets
dropped off at daycare and i just sit at
home playing animal crossing but no one
will buy my bugs or fossils i'm
desperate for some normal human
interaction take i'm serious i don't
know if i can do this job and still be
an equal parent i mean who's gonna pick
up mac on the odd days and who's gonna
bathe him on the even days and who's
gonna do the cooking and who's gonna
figure out we'll figure all that stuff
out how can you be so sure
i just know
for weeks we've been trying to figure
out how you can do your new job and
still have us be there for mac as much
as we want and
i really think this is it yeah but we
have other options yeah
but i think this is the best one
look you know i was scared about having
kids cause i didn't want to be like my
dad
but if i do this
i have a chance to be the exact opposite
and i don't want mac to ever feel the
way i felt growing up and i get that i
really do
but you love being a detective
i know
it's all i ever wanted to be
until now
now
all i care about is what's best for our
family and ames this is it
i mean you've earned this incredible
opportunity you can't do it halfway it's
too important
and mac's my little buddy
i want to be at home with him you really
think you'll be happy
i don't want you to give up your dream
job just for me
i have a new dream job now
trust me i wouldn't say it if i didn't
mean it
you